terminada la primera vuelta de las
elecciones francesas ya se conocen las
predicciones sobre las próximas
intenciones de los votantes franceses
54% de los encuestados por la empresa de
sondeos ipsos afirma que tiene intención
de votar en manuel bacón en la segunda
vuelta miras que 46% tiene previsto
respaldar a marín depp en un resultado
que estaría mucho más ajustado que en
2017 cuando el actual presidente se
impuso a la líder ultraderechista con el
66% de los votos y juró su primer
mandato durante las próximas dos semanas
mahoney lepén harán todo lo posible para
convencer a los ciudadanos franceses de
que les voten pero para una gran parte
de los electores que piensan sufragar
esa elección ya está hecha los
candidatos de todo el espectro político
han pedido a sus seguidores que apoyen
al presidente mientras que el recién
llegado a la extrema derecha a eric se
mucho apoyo al epp en el líder
izquierdista ya look collection llamó
esta vez a bloquear a la otra derecha
después de negarse a aconsejar a sus
votantes en 2017 un llamamiento que
podría tener un grave efecto en los
resultados después de que menciona
müller a más de una quinta parte de los
votos pero animar a la gente a acudir a
las urnas también será una de las
prioridades de los candidatos en la
primera vuelta se estima que un 26 por
ciento de los votantes se negó a votar
un aumento de lo que ya había sido una
alta tasa de abstención en 2017